we're calling these our quarantine
Diaries our quarantine confession holes
where are you huh you're hunkering down
in Malibu
I'm hunkering down in Malibu we're going
between our home and my husband's office
is down the street and right now I'm
outside getting a little fresh air
so yeah we're in Malibu and you're her
staying at home with your husband your
teenage daughters your younger daughter
and all the gods happy to be spending
all this quality time with the kids but
they're fried away already bored and
doing schoolwork and they're teenagers
the older ones and you know it's but you
know what I think it's also good for you
you really really really eight and you
see what's important and things that you
love and sometimes it's the simplest
things can I ask how like co-parenting
works while people are quarantined like
are there more face times with their dad
what's happening you know right now
they're trying to figure out all their
work and you know I just got back from
Europe I was in Spain I was in Madrid
and was lucky enough to be able to get a
flight out so right now we're spending a
lot of time with the kids and setting up
all their schoolwork their online stuff
so reason for everything and you know
like in our family look at you know the
positives out of it and I think it's
good for especially my kids generation
to see that you can also find things to
do around the house yeah how are you
keeping occupied what are you doing well
I had a bit of jet lag when I first got
back but it's also been a great time to
do spring cleaning clean out the closet
organize things
clothes cook a lot and you know it's
been it's been good actually that part
of it and I know that there's obviously
so much suffering and everything outside
of that but the
Silver Lining is all of us being
together and you know family yeah all
that quality time hopefully we all don't
get sick of each other by next week
we'll do this again in a week yes I'll
just keep checking in but in Madrid you
were filming a new TV show with Jane
Seymour right I loved you were having a
crazy period garb on Instagram except
what that project was well in darkness
and my mom actually looks right across
the street from here where we're at but
we have fun and it's great and I cannot
wait until we're back in production
obviously we had to shut down like so
many different productions had to and we
all got out safely and everyone's
healthy knock on wood and you know it's
all good
has this impacted any of like Eloise's
day-to-day because I know she has
special needs I don't know if she's like
missing out on any sort of like
therapeutic treatments or anything like
that has she been affected by this she's
actually been good because a lot of her
stuff is very private and everyone's
healthy so it's a you know it's ever I
think that things have changed a little
bit for her too but more so for the
older girls who are in school and our
oldest daughter Sammy turned 16 and she
was supposed to take her driving test
and unfortunately the very disappointed
that it was cancelled I also think that
it's actually you know this is part of
life and we have to deal with things
that are presented to us and I think
it's just makes everyone stronger and
closer together yeah I think that's the
message right now focus on the simple
maybe turn off the news a little bit
take some breathing time focus on family
do whatever you can get your mind off of
this kind of anxiety inducing experience
right absolutely when I was growing up
like a lot of us we didn't have all the
the internet and everything and it was
about when you get home from school you
do your work you're with your family
your dinner together you make they're
together make dessert whatever it is
it's nice to also have that time to
really reconnect to which has been good
for us and snack on chips yes if I eat
one more potato chip I think I'm gonna
explode I love them so much and then
your outfit every day it's like your
malibu uniform right now uniform my
sweatshirt my Lulu Lemon pants and my
eggs kind of a classic look haven't ya
haven't adjusted much there in this time
no what are you binging on TV are you
watching anything
we loved Aaron and I love to watch
stand-up comics and we're watching a lot
of Bill burr we loved him
yeah we loved the laughs so and
especially right now I think it's fun
and good to laugh Oh a hundred percent
yeah we're gonna get some entertainment
of a different kind soon though the
trailer for Beverly Hills came out this
week exactly what your reaction was to
that well you know trailers are meant to
hopefully get people to want to watch a
show or a movie and I definitely think
that this trailer delivered people want
to watch the show which is good but
could maybe looks be a little deceiving
of what we saw you don't want to be here
then go
don't try and destroy my family
what if she's manipulating me you sent a
cease-and-desist
who told you that you're so angry
there's a lot of stuff that goes on in
this season for sure it was you know
challenging season for me to say the
least yeah yeah I'm sure it feels
different than your first season first
it was smooth very much so yes no this
was something I was not expecting at all
there's been a lot of talk out there and
I know we're gonna have to watch and see
everything unfold to get every side of
the story but what do you want the fans
to know going into this season what do
they need to know from your point of
view well I think you know I also look
at it from you know you want people to
watch our show we want people to watch
the show and you know there's a lot of I
don't know it was just that I was very
much caught off guard and you know the
subject matter that seems to be in all
the tabloids of late Denise there is a
side of you that is hidden oh she's not
who she pretends to be I don't deserve
this that is a huge thing to be saying
what could be that bad
I don't know I think it's kind of
disgusting that they even talk about it
but that's something they choose to and
you know I had worse things said so you
know I can rise above it this is true I
don't you are so strong because you have
been put through the wringer time and
time again I don't know how you handle
it well thank you I I am strong but that
doesn't mean that it doesn't you know
I'm human too
but I have a very solid marriage and I
you know my husband we just rise above
it and people will say what they'll say
and you know in the big picture we can't
worry about that stuff this is true and
again it's Aaron's birthday so we say
happy birthday to Aaron and I'm still
trying to figure out what's handling
because I cannot even bake them a cake
there isn't even flour available no
baked goods anyway no I can't believe it
can vibrate it the grocery stores where
we've gone to stuff but that's alright
was celebrated just gonna kick another
time to yeah I feel like everyone right
now whose birthday is like March and
April it's you'll get to celebrations
and chorus and celebration and then
you'll actually get to do it whenever we
can collapse and one you will never
forget yes that's true for better for
worse I guess of all of your projects
what movie or TV show you've done do you
want people to binge while they're at
home you know I don't like to watch
myself when I look back at every project
I always think of what happened off
camera and behind the scenes and us
hanging out and where I was personally
those are the memories that I really
have from everything but you know
whatever anyone wants to watch you know
if you were like in the studio doing an
interview we would take a picture
together so I'm gonna take a selfie with
you all right thank you I love this no I
have to say this is actually kind of
nice right it's like on your own terms
there we go
well enjoy this new quarantine life
thank you you will get to see you soon
if not in person we'll get to watch you
on TV April 15th and if not I'm gonna
like do another one of these to let you
know how us moms are do
having the kids home all the time yeah
I'll need to know if like tequila intake
has upped at all over the course so far
he has not fret asked me in a few days
or in a week we'll reconnect it thank
you so much
yeah
[Music]